Apple's 24 inch iMac blew our minds when
it came out a couple years back with its
super thin design that is only possible
by putting the Entire Computer inside of
the chin and it hasn't really been
getting any love from Apple for almost
two years but we just got a massive
League bomb from Mark German as you can
see right here in his power on
newsletter that he just put out
yesterday and it looks like we are
finally getting a new iMac this year yes
this year I was not expecting that
because I thought we'd have to wait on
the M3 MacBook Air first then about half
a year later iMac but no it's coming
this year so in this video we're going
to go through all of the leaks and how
things changed so quickly including some
details about the spring event and some
changes to the 15-inch MacBook Air leaks
now here we have the Bloomberg article
from Mark and out of nowhere the iMac
has apparently entered in advance
Advanced stage of development called
engineering validation testing or EVT so
it is going to be coming with the same
24 inch screen size as the current model
from two years ago and apparently even
the same colors however it is going to
be more powerful with a new M2 series
chip to replace the M1 which we know of
course is going to happen however some
of the internal components are going to
be relocated and redesigned and even the
process for attaching the iMac stand is
going to be different probably more
efficient now we do have the actual code
names of the IMAX as well we have j433
and
j434 and it's not expected to go into
mass production for at least three
months which means it is not going to be
shipping until the second half of the
year at the earliest so even here he's
still saying there is a chance it might
get delayed until the spring of next
year which I think that's what's going
to happen but we're gonna have to wait
and see now he did give us a bunch of
info about other Macs but I'll get into
that in just a second because I've got
to talk about the iMac coming sooner
than expected and why we thought it was
not going to be coming until later well
first of all on August 5th from 2022
Mark German gave us some details about a
bunch of Macs and it was missing from
Apple's plans yes the iMac with the M2
Chip was missing which was kind of weird
but it led us to believe that Apple was
skipping the M2 Chip design of the iMac
and likely because the M2 Chip is a
stopgap chip and it wouldn't really make
that big of a difference in terms of the
actual experience and last month he
basically said the same thing the new
iMac was not expected to launch until
late 2023 at the earliest but now he got
a bunch of new details now the reason I
thought it would not come until spring
of 2024 is because with the M1 version
the M1 MacBook Air and the MacBook Pro
and the Mac Mini they came out in
November of 2020 only about six months
later we got the 24 inch iMac so Apple
decided to delay it likely to give more
attention to the iMac by itself instead
of jam packing four Macs into the same
November event and that's why I thought
spring 2024 makes sense because I
thought we'd have to wait until the fall
to get the M3 MacBook Air and then that
delay and of course there is a bunch of
leaks and evidence to back up the claim
of the M3 MacBook Air coming in the
second half of 2023 with a three
nanometer chips which perfectly Falls in
line because we are expecting the a 17
bionic chip for the iPhone to come with
three nanometer technology from tsmc and
that of course isn't happening until
September so it's only natural for the
M3 chip built on three nanometer to come
after that a17 champ but apparently Mark
German thinks that apple is completely
changing the way they do things and he
thinks we might actually get three
nanometer M3 chips before the iPhone a17
chip so let's get into those other Mac
details but first a quick word from our
sponsor pulse way need access to all
your systems while on the go with pulse
way the all-in-one it monitoring and
management platform you can do just that
access systems remote in run scripts all
of it from any device closest to you try
it free today using the link below now
getting back to the mark gurman article
this right here is crazy aside from the
iMac apple is scheduled to launch about
3 new Max between late spring and summer
now that right there is crazy because we
thought we're getting a March event with
a 15-inch MacBook Air and a Mac Pro
which matches up to some of those Macs
but here he's saying no we're not
getting any of that until late spring
which is months from now and even
crazier here's what he says one of them
is going to be the 15-inch MacBook Air
code named j515 then the first Mac Pro
with apple silicon j180 and an update to
the 13-inch MacBook Air
j513 what I thought that was coming at
the end of the year what is it doing
going between late spring and summer
that does not make sense and that's
mainly because the 13-inch MacBook Air
already has the M2 Chip so if it comes
out this summer what is it supposed to
get the M3 well that's not supposed to
be ready until the end of the year after
to the a17 chip so the only way this
makes sense is if apple is literally
getting the M3 chip done early and
releasing it on these Macs before the
a17 chip for the iPhone that's the only
thing that makes sense I personally
thought that the 15-inch MacBook Air
would be on a mid-year cycle to where
you have the 15 inch releasing in the
spring by itself no 13 inch with the
regular M2 Chip and then later this fall
we would just get the 13 inch M3 and
then kind of in the spring times we
could be getting that 15 inch update but
no markerman says they're coming at the
same time and he's saying it makes sense
for them to come with the three
nanometer chip and even crazier to me
he's saying that Apple has been clear it
wants to put its Mac raid processors on
an annual upgrade cycle like the a
series chips in the iPhone I personally
thought it's a 1.5 year cycle for the M
chips where they skip the occasional
agent ship but he's saying annual
upgrades and wow if it really comes the
summer then I guess he is right so the
big question is are we actually getting
a March event or at least a spring event
and if the 15 inch isn't coming then
what is because we did get some leaks
saying that the 15-inch MacBook Air
would be launching in the spring of 2023
and then we got another leak from
Maurice young saying that the actual
display production has begun and it's
launching in April which is not late
spring it's early spring and that's from
Ross young and then of course we have
the Mac Pro leaks which I'll get into in
just a second but look what just
happened over the weekend this is crazy
sources have been saying that apple is
planning a product briefing next week
which is actually this week for the
iPhone 14 to launch in yellow and the
crazy thing is the leaks point to it
happening on 2 Tuesday which is actually
for you guys watching this video today
so by the time you watch this they could
have already released the yellow iPhone
and these new iPhone 14 case colors two
of them right here and a new purple and
kind of orangey leather and maybe even
some apple watch bands those could be
getting announced by press release now
that is very important because because
last year we had a March event and
during that event is when they revealed
the new iPhone colors for the pro and
the regular model both in green
alongside the new cases and everything
else were released at the event so if
we're getting press releases for those
new colors coming this week or today
then what does that mean for this spring
event
why is Apple not holding those for the
spring event if it's happening that
likely means that the spring event is
canceled completely and then that would
make sense why we might not get a
15-inch MacBook gear until later like
Mark German is saying and that's what
Sammy fathi previously at Mac Rumors is
saying he doesn't think there's going to
be an Apple event this month with the
reports of late spring and summer for
the Max and a new press release for
these iPhone colors so that is extremely
disappointing and now of course we have
the last thing that could have been
released at the spring event which is
the Mac Pro and of course the reason we
thought it makes sense for coming out of
spring event is because of the iOS 16.4
software leak from nine to five Mac
pointing at a new compute module which
only makes sense to go into a Mac Pro
and of course we know that these
mid-year huge iOS updates usually come
alongside or after a spring event which
is why we thought the Mac Pro was coming
but we also have this leak from Ross
young who said that Apple's rumored
27-inch display with many LEDs has been
delayed yet again which means it's not
coming for a couple of months maybe not
even until the summer and my issue with
this is that I believe it can only
launch alongside the new Mac Pro it
can't get delayed and launched by itself
it has to be shown off at the same time
so what if at WWDC we're also getting
the Mac Pro and the VR headset
everything and we're not getting a
spring event and if all that happens I
don't know because it's just too much
happening at one time so I guess we're
gonna have to wait and see you guys let
me know your thoughts on the new iMac
coming down in the comment section below
let me know when you think is coming
this year or in the springtime next year
thanks for watching hopefully you enjoy
this click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one check out
one of those two right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]